[Music]
hello everybody and
welcome to et live's a recap of the 56th
acm awards
i'm cassie delaura what a night down in
nashville for the acms more than 25
artists performed over 30 songs
throughout three different iconic
venues in nashville it was one heck of a
night there's so much to recap
let's hit just a few of the highlights
from country music's
biggest party starting with maren morris
who took home
two impressive wins including female
artist of the year and song of the year
for
the bones meanwhile from performing at
dollywood while in her teens to winning
her first
acm awards carly pierce had an
incredible night
taking home two trophies for her i hope
you're happy now duet with lee bryce
single of the year and music event of
the year
not to mention she and lee slayed the
stage
performing speaking of performances from
gabby barrett's
stripped-down performance of the good
ones to carrie underwood and cece winans
taking us to church with the gospel
medley of amazing grace and how great
thou art
y'all i dang near cried my eyelashes off
and then
not to mention we had marin morris and
ryan heard steamy performance
that had a lot of people probably
needing to go to church what a
night of live music lastly
a history making acms with more
representation than ever before four
black artists receive nominations this
year
five black artists took the stage and we
cannot forget about our hostess
with the mostest mickey guyton who held
the reigns of the show
for the night alongside keith urban
y'all we have
so much to break down that i cannot
stand here
and do it alone which is why i enlisted
some friends of mine
from the country music industry we have
singer songwriter brittany spencer
joining us
and apple music countries ty bentley
host of the ty bentley show
y'all thank you so much for taking time
to hang out with us and recap the acms
first want to ask you overall what were
your thoughts of the show
brittany i'll start with you oh
my goodness it was so good you
just you don't always know like how good
something's gonna be especially like
during this covet time but oh my
goodness
it was phenomenal every performance was
completely nailed to perfection
the presenters uh just my girl mickey
killed it
i am uh i honestly i'm just a happy
camper after watching this awards show
it was
so so good i love that ty what about you
what'd you think
yeah i'll say the same thing coming into
the night i was a little bit confused
about how we ended up in another
entertainer of the year category
you know award show where there are no
females represented and then i saw
things starting to build has got closer
and closer to tonight that made me
really excited about
representation of country music and how
we're sharing it with the world
and it felt more alive and live than
anything that we as country music fans
have gotten to experience in the last
12 months at least i'm looking at lady a
performing
on the side of the river here in
nashville on tv and it's right next to
my window which is looking at the same
backdrop i could literally see
the sky's the same color and the same
break in the clouds and i got
i was thrilled i was like we gotta get
snacks go to concessions it was just a
blast i loved it
i think keith nailed it at the beginning
in his opening monologue he said
nashville is back you guys feel that
energy down in nashville
heck yeah i definitely do it felt like
it was representing our town
i love it all right you mentioned
entertainer of the year we obviously
have to talk about the biggest award
of the night we were very sad to see
that carrie wasn't nominated this year
it was dominated by
all men in the category luke combs luke
bryan thomas rhett chris stapleton
and eric church of course luke bryan
took
home the trophy were you guys
surprised with this did you think luke
was going to win because i'm not going
to lie my money was not on luke bryan
well blame my ignorance i uh i actually
just
honestly i just didn't know how we could
have uh this category this year because
of covet
but honestly everyone there is so
deserving um
they all worked so hard i was shocked to
not see
carrie underwood i was shocked to not
see a few people um
like marin morris as well and so um
you know i don't know how we had a
category of all men i don't know how
that happened again but uh
i don't know i'm congrats to luke bryan
and definitely wishing him a speedy
recovery
you know congratulations congrats it's
interesting you mentioned
how we could have this category during
the pandemic and ty i wanted to ask you
you know what is it could you remind
everyone kind of what
an entertainer of the year win you know
entails it's not just
putting out an album or touring it's
kind of overall being like
in the zeitgeist you got to keep in mind
like luke is someone who's
you flip on the channel he's on american
idol like all of that
goes into the category consideration
right
yeah i think that's you know this
category is one of those where you look
at it is so esteemed because
it feels like the category that's most
personally
connected to fans it's the one where the
artists who really enjoy
putting out music because it meant
something to them get to find out how
that music was received
and you know this year in particular
it's not just about the concert and it's
not just about
what the fans are experiencing on that
evening it's about the way that you're
representing country music to the world
and you're right
luke bryan more than anybody else is
like he's that guy right now he's on
idle he's out
doing uh pranks with his wife um he was
entertaining to me just going on
vacation because he keeps hooking
himself with
you know fishing hooks in his thumb and
falling down on the snow and i just get
to watch that and be entertained so he's
literally been
entertaining me this year where there is
nothing happening live at all
he's literally everywhere except at the
acms because of his moment 19
uh diagnosis which again brittany like
you mentioned
we send our well wishes to luke i know
he is a part of american idol tonight so
it's good to see that he
is on the mend but uh moving on you guys
the academy of country
music you know is really making good
this year on their word about
country needing to be more welcoming to
artists of color and we saw that tonight
with
nominations wins um performances
and then also of course we cannot forget
about mickey guyton being the first
black female to
host the acms ty i'll start with you i
want to ask you
do you think the acms met the mark
tonight
i you know what i really love is that
they've started the transition and to me
that's
sort of admitting that it needs to start
happening is a big big big
step it's bigger than some people
realize what we have to do now
as you know people like myself people
like you cassie like brittany
is to continue to encourage that sort of
recognition
to happen there's so many amazing
artists and that's not just
necessarily artists of color although
man i am such a big fan
if anyone needs a great song to make you
feel immediately guilty even if you're
not you go listening to britain spencer
the stars don't work anymore and you'll
find out what i'm talking about
there are amazing talents uh artists of
color
artists who represent the lgbtqia plus
community
and i'm finding that their music is some
of the best music and then
it's our job to continue to push for
them to be represented in this way
that's been revered
and frankly if it doesn't start to
happen and that change doesn't continue
i think the reverence goes away for
these awards because otherwise they lose
their credibility about
the type of music and the quality of
music their record very well said
brittany do you
feel the tide changing in country music
right now
i do i think it's slowly but surely
happening
and tonight is just a testament to um to
that tide
and i think that um like ty said it's
going to be
um such an impactful thing in just the
years to come
tonight was very important um i think
that
we are going to see people have more
hope and uh
actually believe that they can actually
do this thing and think that
i mean particularly people of color and
people who are part of the lgbtqia plus
community
they're going to see country music as
less of an uphill battle
which is usually the case so many people
think man if i pursue this thing
it's going to be a long time and
suddenly this 10-year town becomes a
15-year
venture for me and i think that we're
going to start seeing more people
kind of just come out the woodworks and
just do what we're seeing right now
which is bring a whole other level of
innovation to the genre
that only just benefits everybody and
makes this space so much more fun
and beneficial and lucrative and just
and just
fun you know i'm i'm ready for that i'm
ready for that
does tonight give you hope for your
artistry
absolutely um it definitely gives me
hope i spent so many years as a kid
thinking
that i couldn't do half of the things
that i'm doing today
because i didn't see anybody that looked
like me um
and and i say even just privately to my
friends if we can just get past
the race issue we can start talking
about other things i didn't think i
could be a singer because i wasn't ever
a size 2.
or because just sonically i want to
diversify this space in so many ways
and so if we can get through race if we
can get through
gender and identity issues that are
within the genre
we can start tackling so many other
things and this just becomes so much
more
fun and welcoming and inviting to all
sorts of people from all different walks
of life
and uh i do feel encouraged tonight and
i'm hopeful
um that we just continue on this path
and that it's not just a trend
i love that you mention your experience
as a kid because
i feel like there are so many young
children who watch the acm awards
tonight
and we're able to see people like them
children of color being able to
watch these performances watch mickey
hosts see the winds
and and say wow i can do that one day
which which brings me to
these incredible performances and the
history that was made
on stage first off we have carrie
underwood and cece winans
who literally took us to church with an
incredible
gospel medley uh before we dive into
that in case you missed their
performance
here's a little clip of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
making her acm awards debut yeah
brittany what's going through your mind
right now okay i am such a huge fan i
can't tell you how many times i didn't
sing alabaster box in church because it
was one of the few songs that i actually
knew all the words to
so i am i am church to the core so of
course seeing cece juanas was incredible
and carrie is just a phenomenal force
and i mean i've sung back up for her
several times
and she she is a force and just watching
my worlds just kind of come together
the way it did to my country and gospel
it's just
it's a dream and the whole time i was
just throwing things
you know i like anyway i'm gonna tell
you what i threw up my tv tonight
but i threw a few things because that's
what you do in church you throw things
when somebody is singing their tail off
and that's what happened tonight
it was a lot of people joining forces of
course carrie and cece and then you had
dierks bentley sharing the stage with
husband and wife duo the war entreaty
for a cover of youtube
youtube's pride in the name of love
which dirks has you know been covering
this song for years but
ty i'm gonna i'm gonna kick this
question to you what do you think the
message was
of this collaboration tonight on this
stage at the acm awards
i will tell you right now i'm such a big
fan of dirk's bentley as a human being
and who he is and the way that he wants
to continue to represent
this great talented people and country
music and bring them to the forefront
and
man watching this i felt the same thing
that i was throwing stuff too you know
what i mean like but not on purpose
though and stuff like sort of like i
just couldn't sit still
and i had a baby on my lap at the moment
i have a new baby in the house and i was
like
my wife and i are just like what is
happening this is incredible
and i thought that this um for me i will
say the tie back to 1984 was really
interesting and that's partly me
being like a part of apple music now you
know 1984 holds
missing hints for me and then the the
song itself pride was released back in
1984 the last time we saw a black host
on the acm award
was charlie pride who joined some others
in 1984. and
i really believe that was a big part of
this message it was that
we want to now represent as many
perspectives
and give you as many chances to enter
country music feeling like
your story is right there being
reflected through the music that we're
performing and some of that is the
styling
of the way that that arrangement was put
together unbelievable and the history
that dirk has with station inn which
people in nashville
know is such a historic proving ground
stomping ground just a hangout
for the bluegrass community to see
these two come in and this husband and
wife said
crush it and then the vocals themselves
are one thing but the message of
that song is so pop it speaks to one of
the greatest leaders that our country's
ever seen in martin luther king jr
and uh and even you know the watching if
you're a music fan you know watching for
that little lyric i was like which one
was they saying
the originals bono wrote them or will
they say early evening and
he's saying early evening and just to me
that really put a poignancy on what was
happening there and the music just
enveloped me
and the spirit of what i wish country
music for anybody who's just being
introduced to it was right there
and dirks is always someone who
practices what he preaches he's someone
who
it's not for show you look at who he has
with him on his team behind the scenes
you know his his video for gone was
nominated for video of the year
and he had a black director on board for
that you know he's someone who
practices what he preaches and i think
that was such a special moment that he
enlisted the warren treaty tonight
um you guys i want to move on to another
performance tonight again i mentioned
joining forces we saw so many epic
teaming up tonight teaming up i can't
even
miranda lambert and l king have me like
so shook that i can't even get my words
out
y'all this is going to be the anthem of
the summer i'm talking about
drunk and i don't want to go home before
we dive into this i know
brittany that was me at my desk when
they were performing this song for all
y'all at home
take a listen this is how the acm awards
were kicked off tonight
oh my gosh i need some bedazzled leather
jackets over here we all need them
okay you guys brittany i'll start with
you why
is this duo the duo that country music
needs right now
i mean it's it's just phenomenal in
every way i've been listening to this
song for weeks and
every time it comes on i just want to
hear it again it was just
such a great show opener i mean the
outfits were amazing i was here for the
fringe i was here for that for this
collab i mean the moment it was
announced
it was just good and it's just honestly
i just think it set the tone for the
whole show
just two incredible women just going for
it and doing it they did that tonight
i know it's about i know it's about like
a girls night out but ty doesn't make
you want to like go
out to the bar with your friends i mean
everyone's been cooped up at home during
the pandemic everyone wants to
go out and get drunk at the bar right
that's what was painful about this
performance it's like i'm watching this
and
i'll tell you this i remember the moment
i first heard that song in this room it
was facing that wall
listening to those speakers and i was
like are you kidding me i cannot wait to
play this for people
and as i'm listening to what i love is
you've got l king you've got miranda
lambert who are
un uh inarguably just badass
amazing human beings who everyone knows
are as tough as nails if they want to be
and as talented as anyone else in this
industry
but this song is a literal little bit
of a fit throwing a little bit of a fit
like any of our friends have
i've had my buddies call me and be like
ah i'm not going home just go without me
we've all had that night out that just
feels you feel so alive
that you just are like whiny about not
wanting to leave right now
and it's not a wine it's an anthem and
it sparks every truth and authenticity
that country music is supposed to be
about in this way that just makes you
charge back up and i love that this song
is
what started what set the tone for the
night
i know it's a sunday night and i have to
work tomorrow but i am
absolutely jamming to this song on my
way home tonight
all right let's move on last but not
least my personal favorite performance
of the night
maren morris and ryan hurd making their
acm debut
performance uh or performance debut as a
couple this is ryan hurd's first time
taking the acm awards stage
they perform their duet chasing after
you oh my goodness was it steamy
take a look
from the hand-holding to the smooch at
the end oh this was everything
ty do you see marin and ryan kind of
evolving into
a timid faith-style country couple
i hope so i look at them and i and that
was what i was thinking cassie when i
was watching the show tonight i'm like
yeah they'd be coming to miss faith
and then you almost like want to be
protective for them because what tim and
faith have pulled off in country music
to have that relationship
and some of the biggest tours of all
time together with their soul-to-soul
tours
is not a normal outcome for a
relationship it's a recipe for disaster
in a lot of cases and i
love both of these people as people but
when you watch ryan and you watch marin
and you watch them do so well what they
do
i think that they have an opportunity to
create that and
man the runs that marin can put together
vocally you don't even realize
how incredible the decision she's making
on a harmony aren't how hard they are
until you really like take a moment and
listen to it it's insane and at the end
i was watching it and brittany i don't
know i'm not a performer um but i feel
like
when you are in that moment as a
performer you're supposed to get
all the way up to the moment right so
you don't quite kiss
you hold it and i thought are they going
to hold it are they going to kiss i just
wanted to know
and then marin went in and kissed and go
they are
really in love i love this it's adorable
we got the smooch we got the kiss
on that note y'all we gotta wrap up this
segment but britney spencer singer
songwriter down in nashville thank you
so much
for joining us everyone make sure you
check out brittany spencer's music
and of course hi bentley thank you so
much and you can check out
ty's show the thai bentley show on apple
music thank you guys so much we still
have so much more to come here on et
live
we are talking all things fashion the
ladies brought it tonight from the red
carpet oh kelsey ballerini and emerald
right there i absolutely love it
fashion from the red carpet to their
performances all of this after the break
do you push through migraines mom are
you okay
absolutely imagine if you could prevent
a migraine day before it happens
take mgality once a month to help
prevent migraine days
it cut the number of monthly migraine
days by fifty percent or more for some
people
don't use if allergic to amgality
allergic reactions such as itching rash
hives and trouble breathing can occur
even days